we are getting ready to taste community
user-submitted secret menu item pretty
much just drinks that people made up I
love Starbucks Starbucks this morning I
got a gold card they recently changed
the point system which caused a huge
uproar in the Starbucks community but I
think we've all settled down
oh no these are like frappuccinos aren't
they these are like blended green tea
peppermints aren't they peppermint
lemonade all right already
yeah nope
what wow this is really good although it
does taste like a cough lozenge or get I
think that's a really good sign person
who invented this would drink orange
juice after brushing their teeth who
like not be bothered by it yeah maybe a
young dude I'm gonna order this non
thought I don't get it
but I'll try it yeah I got it is like
Captain Crunch that's clean that aside
Corey it's disgusting first of all it's
a disrespect to strawberry I don't think
I would order this again but I would
want to show this to other people you
think this is like a giant pickle or hi
people
I can't take another Captain Crunch I
cannot take another Captain Crunch drink
why is there a banana in here I'm Tony
banana have no place outside of a
bananas is really good I like banana
bread so I disagree with I don't know
I'll be honest I've never had banana
bread it was a bread shaped like a
banana drop the cameras go get him
banana bread way are there emerges I
love this it could have more chocolate
but it's also perfect the way it is you
know I never liked banana splits as a
child so stressed out oh okay you don't
like us cuz it isn't good the barista
was politely like just going okay cool
anything else and then the guy or girl
ordering it was like oh yeah okay mint
and then she's a cool anything else
protein powder we should kill anything
else okay gotcha gotcha I don't even
know what matcha is no one's ever told
me I quit
I'm just think with my normal Starbucks
drinks I will give props to anyone who
came up with those because they're very
creative I would never think to ask for
anything that look wasn't explicitly on
the menus people are brave their
courageous they're pioneers you're doing
Starbucks they really are or does
anything on Starbucks is just you can
you can get whatever you want and that's
probably the beauty of it actually then
everybody can get their own specific
trinkets or book even though it may not
appeal to a wide audience true that
drink is for you boo I still don't know
what much is